check out the story from the new york
times let's jump right into it new
allegations of cover-up
by cuomo over nursing home virus toll in
a private conversation the governor's
top 8 admitted
that data was withheld on nursing homes
where more than 10
000 new yorkers have died during the
pandemic they say the remarks by the top
aide melissa de rasa made in what was
supposed to be a private conference call
with democratic lawmakers came as a
cascading series of news reports that a
court order
have left mr cuomo a third term democrat
scrambling
to contain the political fallout over
his oversight of nursing homes
where more than 13 000 people have died
in the pandemic
and in the state cnn takes a little bit
further saying
new york new york governor's top aide
admits administration delayed the
release of covet 19 deaths
in long-term care facilities over
federal investigation concerns
you got to be kidding me they thought
there was an investigation coming so
they started hiding the fact
that cuomo killed these people i've been
mad about this for a long time
and now it's it's substantially worse
because i've been telling people do you
know
6 500 elderly were killed by cuomo when
he put these sick people in his nursing
homes then they contracted it and died
it was actually much more than that 13
thousand people
damn that's crazy well that's the
estimate some people say it's even
bigger than that some people are
estimating it's fifteen thousand people
the effects and the ramifications of
this are absolutely
brutal i mean there's multiple calls for
criminal prosecution of andrew cuomo
immediately
jail now no questions about it they're
not give him a trial yes
give him a trial but right to jail uh
seriously this is absolutely
insane there are some actual i never
thought i would say this in my life
there's some actual democrats in new
york with a spine
and they're actually calling for andrew
cuomo to lose his emergency covet powers
that needs to be
that needs to happen immediately how
about step down how about that
how about not like lose your powers i
let you step down
call the day i mean once again theorists
are right right isn't it i mean like
they said it forever
yeah and here we are once again
theorists are right well but but but
this was publicly known this is what
blows my mind pro-publica
and not a conservative organization mind
you ran the story saying
6 500 deaths that one was bad enough
what was this dude thinking putting sick
people
literally next to the most vulnerable
we've been talking about what we got to
do to open up the economy and the first
thing is protect the vulnerable the
elderly and those who are
immunocompromised
and what does cuomo do the opposite he
stuffs what it was at 9 000 people
yeah around 9 000 that we know of for
now because there's a massive cover up
here
as hospitals and field hospitals the
jacob javits center central park and
even huge u.s
naval ships were ready to take on sick
people
what did he do send him back to nursing
homes under his own directive
the question is why yeah what is it why
did this scumbag
kill 13 000 people and why now
are they only calling him out now we
knew this happened months ago
so luke you mentioned some democrats
have a spine they said
nothing for how many months six seven
months we've been complaining about the
show periodically
we bring it up periodically cuomo killed
these people
and to add insult to injury como is
literally meeting with biden now
trying to get federal bailout money for
the state for the mistakes that he made
for the lockdowns that he initiated and
the lives that he ruined in more ways
than one meanwhile what does the biden
administration do
they passed a bailout bill that's
probably going to give them a boatload
of money
and they're going after florida florida
yeah places that didn't lock down
has no mandates is actually dealing with
this sickness way better
than of course the new york government
but not but now biden's going to be
literally bailing out new york state or
giving them money for for doing this
essentially if you're reporting them
why he would do this like try to come up
with a reason
trump for the positive right trump yeah
yeah
these deaths were added to the numbers
new york was brutal and how many
they were like 35 000 have died so far
and it seems like a good portion of that
was because of cuomo
on purpose and and i think there's two
things here if i had to guess okay
because i i don't know for sure
why didn't the media go after cuomo hard
why didn't democrats
because it helped them go after trump so
they knew he killed these people and
said you just wait till after november
um why were they taken out of the
nursing homes to begin with who what do
you mean the
they said they were sent back to nursing
homes so well that means they were they
were sent from the hospital
to the nursing home so they were sent
back to the nursing so they were taken
out of the nursing home they got
diagnosed in the hospital
what they were taking out of the nursing
homes because they were sick they went
to the hospital they got diagnosed with
covet and then he was like what are we
gonna do with them send them back to the
nurse some of the people who got sent
were young people
yeah yeah remember it wasn't all guy up
it was it was there was young people for
no reason being put in long-term care
for the elderly in nursing homes
yes wow cuomo killed these people you
got to be careful with that accusation
no
i don't what he didn't take a knife and
cut he wrote one
is reporting now that he's responsible
for this okay
you're the only one defending this i'm
not even defending it yeah you're just
saying the way you phrase
saying that someone killed somebody how
about a guy who lost his mother's death
threw a banner down right here who said
cuomo killed my mom
go tell him that cuomo didn't your tax
dollars fund the drone bombs you didn't
kill those people oh we did yes we did
you didn't yeah yes somebody did with
your people you all contribute to that
and that's why i complain about it but
i'm telling you this right now
when you've got janice dean of fox news
saying that cuomo killed her in-laws
when a guy dropped a banner over a
highway in new york saying cuomo killed
my mom
and they lied about it because they were
being federally invested
they were scared of a federal
investigation so they covered up the
numbers
dude i'm telling you they put sick
people in there the opportunity to put
them on the ships that ship that trump
sent in
don't want to use that could make trump
look good huh didn't want to put him in
the javits center have the actual
capability to save these people so put
them in nursing homes let them all die
and then cover up the numbers
because you're being investigated and
now even democrats are coming after him
i'm i'm sick to my stomach the ship and
nurse or where the ship and the javits
center like
less uh they were the best no one
used them no one was inside of them they
were empty the whole time
yeah the military is some of the best of
the best
the javits center i i we can argue was a
field hospital that was set up and it
wasn't the same as a regular hospital
but to put people in nursing homes makes
made zero sense and there was what you
you brought that guy who beat that that
elderly guy 25 year old guy when he's
recovering from cobit he beat up this
old dude in a nursing home
after he was put in what about the
ventilator what about the ventilators
that he hid
and got busted hi
i mean cuomo got all these ventilators
and
hid them and then went on and started we
need ventilators
we need them and then trump's like
they're right over here dude where you
put them
see when you said about the drone
strikes tim
didn't order the drone strikes cuomo
ordered old people to though it's a
totally different thing our tax dollar
go
to feeding this whole this military
industrial complex
for sure but tim me luke nobody made a
decision hey let's drone strike this
place
imagine how psychotic you have to be to
do this and then say
i'm going to write a book about how
great i did and i get a book deal out of
it
i get an emmy out of this i get
congratulatored
by all the mainstream media
family-friendly show i got so many other
words i want to use here
uh celebrating him uh and propping him
up as this great
leader when in reality he's the complete
opposition
criminal cover-up take a look at how the
media covered this from usa today fact
check
does new york have a stockpile of
thousands of
unneeded ventilators what was the
accusation
against against cuomo that we know they
need the ventilators
and he was having them stockpiled in a
warehouse somewhere so usa today does a
fact check where they say unneeded
ventilators
nobody said they were unneeded that we
were saying we needed them
deploy them i love this here's their
their verdict
the verdict is false while it's true
new york maintains a stockpile of
ventilators not in use
it is incorrect that these machines are
unneeded the current number of
ventilators deployed in the state are
not enough to meet the increasing
challenge
well maybe if the dude used the ones
that he had that were not in use
he could have had him why didn't he use
them you know what man
you you it's not a con it's not a
conspiracy because we know he did it
the question is why we can speculate i
have no idea so is he like hiding them
to get more
well he got caught he was lying like we
don't have enough ventilators truck you
got to send him
and then i think it was trump who said
you have a big stockpile you're not
using
and he was like well and then so the
media comes to his defense
and says unneeded ventilators no one
said
there was a stockpile of unneeded
ventilators they said there were
stockpiles of ventilators
that we needed and they change it that's
how these fact checks work
i always talk about it'll be like did
donald trump have a scoop of ice cream
with sprinkles while it's true that
donald trump did have ice cream there
were no sprinkles nobody accused him of
having sprinkles
it's like donald trump could save a
bunch of puppies from a building and
they'll say
did donald trump save a bunch of puppies
from a burning building
with gym shoes on false big bold letters
and the bottom will say he did save the
puppies but he was wearing
he wasn't wearing gym shoes yeah that's
the manipulation that's how they lie
does uh sanctuary cities have anything
to do with this wasn't there a bunch of
funding cut from
places that were just taken illegal well
there's one real simple explanation i
mean you can get you can get dark with
it and say
he was willing to kill these people
because he hated trump or it could be
new york is facing a massive budget
deficit and a massive debt
and they need money from the federal
government and in order to justify it
they say
oh no look at all these people like oh
jeez you
feds you better give us money we need
the ventilators we we need them
why you got a big warehouse full of them
use the ones you have almost everything
the new york government did when it came
to covid
has backfired against the people whether
it's from the very beginning
fauci said they did it right dude he did
congratulate them
that they did a great job but from the
very beginning they were telling you
don't be racist go out to the chinese
parade
go out it's going to be great chinese
did it in san francisco yeah come on
down to chinatown yeah
so when you look at the leadership here
it failed at
every single level and who paid the
ultimate price the citizenry
who are being brainwashed by the
mainstream media to try to worship these
individuals you shouldn't worship these
people these are criminals
top level notch gangsters that of course
don't give a damn about you
never gave a damn about you and the
sooner you realize that the better your
life will be
they do though i will say i can't stand
the cuomo brothers personally from the
outside i find that they're riding the
coattails of their daddy's last name
and that they're incompetent annoying
ugly dudes
personally i if i met him in person
maybe i would like him one-on-one
and maybe they are mafia like i don't
know that's like some
new york government and has had
notorious been for like
hand-in-hand with the mob the dude
what's the difference between the mob
and the government
yeah what's the difference here
paperwork yeah okay
good point yeah that's it yeah well you
remember he was like comparing himself
he was talking about how him and fauci
are like robert de niro and
and what's his face from all those mob
movies so yeah
he totally has that mentality he's super
powerful
can i remind everybody what the what the
cuomo brothers were doing while andrew
was
killing people uh here's a here's here's
a from cnn.com
chris cuomo teases brother andrew with
giant test swab
and then you've got chris going to be
like hey andrew you got a big nose look
at this big cute tip you got to stick it
in your nose and everyone's laughing and
having a good time that's his brother
this is another thing as his brother was
lying about the quarantine
being sick running around town being
caught for it
faking his own kind of release from
quarantine when he was caught
outside when he was confirmed to be sick
these these brothers are psychopathic
they're insane they from their own
cognitive decisions they knew that that
if they got someone else sick they could
kill them they still went outside
chris never faced any reality for it and
cnn as a whole
pretended that he was quarantined you
saw this story yeah yeah yeah and then
he got caught because he was screaming
at some dude on a bike 30 minutes from
his house
because he owns some other property and
the guy sees him it's like aren't you
supposed to be quarantined he's like
don't you come here tell me what to do
then chris cuomo admits it all on his
radio show by attacking the guy
right he went after the cops
telling me what i can do and then
everyone's like even even ben smith the
new york times
said it's crazy how cnn is like you know
basically lying about this
and then later they had this video where
chris comes out of the basement like i'm
not sick anymore
i'm not a quarantine and we're all like
dude we know he's we're just sitting
there like
my dad is such a fake dude if you watch
his son's face while he's talking in
that video it's so sad that kids are
like oh my god yeah
and then eventually they get traumatized
and then they're in the whole system
too it's like governor newsom's the
exact same thing
quarantine locking everybody down then
his wineries open he's at some
some restaurant chilling with friends
with no mass on it's rules for thee and
not for me
that is what this is basically in my
humble opinion
is an elite purge they're doing whatever
they want not following the laws and
nobody's enforcing the laws and that's
the biggest problem meanwhile
meanwhile suicides of children in
california
this is what people don't get in the
purge the elites are safe and protected
while the poor people are killing
themselves
they're not going to just come out and
be like everybody commit crimes they're
going to be like
we destroy your business then we we mass
print money that goes right into our
pockets from you and how many how much
have people got
man they got like 600 bucks they got 600
bucks congratulations your
entire life was destroyed cuomo
literally killed people
and they laugh about it and then they
get richer
the big box stores the big corporations
get all that stimulus money funneled
right in their pockets because
everything else is closed
you're right it's the purge it's they're
just doing it away because they don't
want the like in reality the purge
wouldn't work because
people could still commit crimes after
the fact so so here's the thing about
the purge right this movie you guys you
guys i'm talking about
for those that are listening one day a
year you can do whatever you want
basically
and the idea is the rich people and the
elites don't got to worry about anything
because they're so powerful and they
have security
but people still commit crimes right so
even if we had one day a year that was
the purge we could get away with it
some people still wouldn't care to get
away with it because some people still
commit crimes
so you imagine this you have a bunch of
elites who get everybody killed
the next day people aren't going to care
about the law they're going to be angry
well this is the way they do it without
actually getting anyone to point the
finger at them
i mean if you take a look at what was
going on in all these cities there is
burning these kids will commit crimes
we're fine these kids are the uh
children of the elite
they go down and they burn down a bur uh
of a middle-class
uh business and then the d.a would just
release them yeah just release them just
it is literally the purge it was rich
kid purge
that's and you when malcolm x and the
unabomber
both say white rich liberals
are the most dangerous thing out there
that's what you're
this is exactly what they're talking
about and if you want to go even deeper
you look at
so many of these these these uh cultural
icons
and how many of them are just rich kids
that just got
never got life messed out of them you
know like did have to go through it
to kill idealism and they just got in
these positions
all their friends are rich in powerful
positions and their message just spread
and that's what 2020 was antifa
was all that just rich kids but i mean
my own
studio in l.a i had friends of mine
bragging about being in these
these riots that they burn and broke
down businesses all around my studio
and i'm like dude i was right there all
my all my hard work was right there if
you would have
busted in there you would have destroyed
all my dreams and you don't care because
you didn't care about black lives you
just want to go out and have fun and
that's
exactly what's happening well they were
locked in they had no other release
valve so when they took away the sports
they took away the entertainment they
locked them in
i mean covid was pretty much the year
that a lot of people realize that the
rich play up by a different set of rules
and hold on two more points as in the
latest news today is also that austria
i don't want to get off this point
that's the purge that riot was the purge
yeah they let them do it
they let everyone run around for weeks
smashing and destroying all across this
country
they literally have they all crossed in
middle class and poor class because
when they tried to go into beverly hills
they shut that down
real quick not the rich people yeah you
see that guy you see that guy
who was like tweeting about cheering on
the riots yeah from espn and then also
he was like oh no now they're by my
house
stop go somewhere else yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah rules for this
is the you know this is an existence
controlled by the rich that have a
different set of rules
as of today we also got the information
that australia just extended their
lockdown for five days
and canada is now requesting that if you
want to come into their country you have
to pay two thousand dollars for
hotel stay and test to again quarantine
we were talking about this yesterday
specifically with the united kingdom
now demanding that if you want to enter
the united kingdom you have to pay two
thousand four hundred dollars
so this is pretty much only going to
allow rich people to travel because you
can't afford
paying two thousand dollars to go to
canada to quarantine for a week has
australia done it yet
uh australia's has has pretty much
banned
most travel uh i i forgot the latest
updates we could probably pull it up but
not a lot of people are allowed to even
enter or even leave australia yeah it
was uh contest
said you got to get your your your test
or whatever to prove
you know you're not sick or whatever you
want to fly well that's what happens in
the united states now if you want to
enter the united states you have to have
a test
yes you're going through the border yeah
uh illegally and i do i mean take a look
at what's going this is all about
getting us used to the
basically social credit score if you
look at the nba
they're doing this contact tracing thing
i mean huge names guys
test positive they're like oh you were
near somebody did they did with kevin
durant he was right about to play and
they pulled him and he can't play
for games that's set in this setting the
president's trying to get us all okay
with that
hey man you you were hanging out with
somebody that we don't like go home and
hang out that's what this is all about
new york proposed that bill i don't know
where it's at right now i think it was
in committee last time
where they were going to set up
detention centers or facilities for
those who are
suspected of having contact with people
who
may be a danger to public health i got
some for you man
there is a video of governor newsom
talking about
you know how he's going to deal with the
homeless and he's working with fema
and i'm telling you this as much as you
see the homeless around there
i'll there's certain place where i gotta
drive to work or drive uh to go see my
kids
and uh you'll see these giant homeless
encampments
and then one day you won't see hardly
any homeless there but the encampment's
there
then the next day you go by the catman's
gone and you're like
where did all this go and i'm telling
you this is how they did it they rounded
them up
at 4am well so there's there's a city in
northern california that does this
they they take homeless people and then
what they
they declare themselves conservators of
the individual's finances
and they lock the homeless person up and
then say until you can prove
you can handle money you're locked up in
san francisco they'll come at 4 a.m with
fire hoses
just that's what i'm watching is going
on man
i know people could call me crazy but
i'm like where is all these people
it was a giant cabinet now it's gone
where'd they go
and you don't see it come back and it's
just like well the uh
what what what new york do was like new
york in the 80s was it giuliani yeah put
all the put all the homeless people on a
bus and then shipped them off to
different cities
that's what happens at la too yeah they
ship
oregon washington and all these other uh
states send their homeless to us well
they're gonna send the homeless people
to like very lefty states and cities
that pay for it the people who live
there
are the ones who reap the benefits of
those policies i think that was called
repopulation
it was like an ancient uh like
punishment
for criminals you just repopulate them
by moving them to a different country
they put people in australia yeah
technically it's illegal to loiter so
maybe that's what they're doing they're
like
this is your punishment thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you